Hello Freak bitches.
They cringe.
And,
and,
but,
but it became like this game of trying to like show that we were going to get
our message across no matter what any human being wanted because we knew we were
so sure that this was what God wanted.
Wow.
What made you leave
a lot of things?
It started my very first sort of conscious doubts came from conversations on
Twitter.
So wow.
Yeah.
Something good God done through Twitter.
Lots of good things.
I also met my husband there.
Oh,
there you go.
While I was still at the church.
Oh,
it's Kinda,
uh,
I don't know that he would use that word to describe himself.
I would actually,
I was just talking to Sam about this and I was like,
when people,
the problem with the word,
when you say atheist,
people think jerk and like selling all.
So many people do.
So many people think that it's like,
oh,
you're absolutely certain that there is no god.
And so it's,
it's a word that I hesitate to use to describe myself too,
but,
but I'm not,
I'm not a believer.
I don't even like to say I'm not a believer because I,
I love people,
I believe in people and that there is so much hope and for people and that we
can,
I don't know.
Anyway,
so conversations that you have on Twitter did,
what do you like?
What,
what doors open your mind?
Right.
So I got on Twitter and it was like an extension of the picket line,
right?
So when you go out there with picket signs and you know,
people would come up to us and ask us questions.
And so it was this,
it was a constant,
a constant conversation.
And so I got on Twitter to take that,
you know,
to,
to the Internet to reach more people.
And so one of the first things I did when I got on Twitter was to attack this
Jewish man named David Abbott Ball,
who ran a blog called judicious.
He was listed as the second most influential Jew on Twitter,
uh,
on this number one.
Um,
I actually can't remember,
not memorable and I'm part of my story,
I guess you can check it.
It's the JTA is list.
If you want to change.
But anyway,
so he was listed as number two,
and uh,
so he responded initially with,
uh,
you know,
sarcasm and,
and,
and hostility.
Um,
but pretty quickly he sort of changed tactics and started instead of like
mocking me,
although he still did do that some too.
Um,
he was asking questions about our picket signs and I started asking him
questions about Jewish theology because I,
I wanted to better know how to counter it,
you know,
to from the scriptures because I was sure that they were wrong.
Jews killed Jesus and,
and they reject him as the Messiah.
And so all of these things,
um,
so,
right,
so we're having this back and forth and this goes on for about a year.
And during that year,
I actually met him twice.
I protested him twice once to his functions or was he giving speeches?
So in Long Beach,
actually at the judicious festival,
they had this Jewish cultural festival.
Great Name.
Yeah,
that's great.
He's great.
Um,
so he,
he was going to be there.
Uh,
and you know,
I went and I was protesting him,
uh,
and he came out to the picket line and it was,
it was one of those like very rowdy pickets.
There was a bunch of a counter protestors and they were,
it was,
I dunno guys dresses like the Easter Bunny and Jesus and you know,
it was actually got pretty violent.
So I was actually super violent.
Well yeah,
and the cops,
this my,
I told you,
we called the cops.
Like the cops were just standing there watching people like actively assaulting
us,
like hitting us.
And so we're like walking around trying to,
you know,
to not be head cause we're,
we're not going to hit back.
We weren't there.
Like I said,
the church is very against violence.
Like they're not going to be violent to people or defend themselves just,
just to,
so I was actually really glad when David came out because he became like a
buffer between me and the rest of the counter protestors because everybody could
tell that he was,
you know,
he's wearing his delicious shirt and whatever.
Anyway,
so,
so the conversation continued there.
And then also at another protest,
uh,
six or seven months later,
um,
and then,
uh,
it was not long after that second protest,
we're talking again and he was asking about one of our signs that said,
death penalty for facts.
And you know,
of course I'm reiterating why the church believes that.
And he has in the book of Leviticus,
God calls for the death penalty for gay gays.
And,
and then enrollments will,
and then the New Testament,
uh,
it's reiterated to commit such things are worthy of death.
So,
um,
and so I'm telling David these things and he says,
it's like,
yeah,
but didn't Jesus say,
let he who is without sin cast the first stone?
And I said,
what we always said to that,
which was,
uh,
we're not casting stones were preaching words.
And he said,
yeah,
but you're advocating that the government cast stones.
And I remember,
you know,
this is all through Twitter.
So I see this message and like I kind of gassed.
And I was like,
I had never connected that Jesus there.
Of course he was talking about the death penalty specifically about the death
penalty.
And we were advocating it.
And so I wasn't sure how to respond,
but he,
David kept,
kept going.
He said,
and what about this member of your church who had a child out of wedlock?
And I said,
what about it like that?
This is another point,
you know,
people,
it was,
you know,
common knowledge.
People knew about this and what throw this in our face.
And we would say the standard of God isn't sinlessness,
it's repentance.
So she doesn't deserve that punishment because she repented.
She stopped,
she wasn't having premarital sex anymore and she knows that it's wrong.
And she changed her mind and she changed her conduct,
which is what repentance is.
And he said,
yeah,
but she would have been killed if you had instituted the death penalty for that
sin.
And it was the first time,
again that I connected,
that if you kill somebody,
as soon as they sin,
they,
you lose the opportunity to repent and be forgiven.
And again,
so I'm just sort of staring at my phone and you know,
in Topeka,
Kansas,
he's in Jerusalem and I really quickly ended the conversation.
I don't even remember quite how,
but it was just sort of this like I hadn't,
I didn't know how to handle this because like I said,
the church is full of lawyers.
They're very intelligent and their arguments and their theology for the most
part is very well constructed and super consistent.
And so for there to be this,
you know,
this,
this hypocrisy,
this contradiction.
I didn't,
my,
like my brain was,
it felt like it was exploding.
So I went to a couple people in the church,
including my mother.
Um,
and the response was,
feel free to stop me at anytime by the way,
I feel like I'm filling.
That's why here.
Um,
so she,
she's reiterated the same verses that I had told David that,
that supported our position,
but she didn't address the contradiction.
And when I seem to unsatisfied with it,
uh,
she said I was getting wrapped around an axle and a just sort of,
you know,
push it aside.
And the response was,
so just to shut,
shut me down.
Uh,
and then to move on to the next thing,
which is,
it's a very human thing,
right?
When somebody puts something in your face that that is this contradiction that
you're not ready to deal with or that you can't,
you,
you know what I mean?
You compartmentalize,
you kind of sort of push it aside and try not to.
So the way that I dealt with it was to,
uh,
stop holding the sign.
Cause I knew that if somebody asked me about it,
I,
I couldn't defend it because I didn't,
I didn't believe it.
But there was nothing else I could do at that point.
And,
but the importance of that conversation,
this is obviously just one small contradiction in one small inconsistency and a
vast,
you know,
we still,
I still believed that everybody outside the church was basically isn't a
completely wrong and,
and evil and or delusional and that the church was basically right except this
one point.
It's a culture of tattle tales,
not out of bad intention,
but because they believe that they're trying to help you.
They don't want you to go down a bad path.
So,
so we know when I,
it was,
it was the,
I first thought of leaving on,
it was July 4th and I was with my sister at the time and when it first occurred
to me that I might,
that I might have to leave the church,
that the church might be wrong.
I thought I had to leave like that second because if it even occurred to me that
meant I didn't belong there and that God was going to punish me and that I,
I just felt like immediately so much guilt and like I was a betrayer booze.
All your social life connected still to the church.
Yeah.
And was this where you had you already known your husband by then?
I had,
yeah,
he was definitely part of it.
So,
but like it wasn't like that.
It's like the beginning,
like,
so,
so he was just another person on Twitter at first.
Um,
and it was,
it was,
it was like friendly conversation and it was,
went over to the front of the course of several months,
um,
I don't know,
eight,
eight or eight months or so,
seven or eight months.
Uh,
and then,
and it was never,
there was never anything,
you know,
about feelings or you know,
relationships are,
all that stuff is total for ventures.
No,
nothing like that.
Like not even like not even anything like nothing.
Like it's just that my mind didn't work that way and that there is,
there can be no relationship like that with outsiders but outsiders,
outsiders.
So you know,
and I actually thought I was never going to get married because most of the
people in the church,
about 80% or so of the people in the church,
there's only 80 people or so anyway.
Or my immediate and extended family.
So I thought there's no way that I'm going to,
I'm just not going to get married.
It was,
it wasn't,
it wasn't like an like an easy thing at first,
but it was just,
it was just the facts on the ground.
You know,
like I,
I could actually ground where you had to date someone inside the church.
There was only 80 people in the church are all your family.
You can't date your family.
Fuck yeah.
Wow.
I mean,
I should say there were a couple of people my age,
like,
and they can't,
they had just joined the church,
like,
you know,
that.
But I had no,
like,
I had no interest in any of them and know,
and uh,
but yeah,
it's,
it was kind of strange,
but I,
so I actually had a dream about meeting,
I should say.
Also my husband at the time,
I didn't know he was totally anonymous on Twitter.
Like I said,
it's just his words.
I didn't know what he looked like.
I didn't know,
you know,
his name or where he lived or anything about him,
uh,
except except these words.
Um,
and he was,
he was just curious and kind and,
and that sort of,
and he loved people.
And so he would sort of always be pushing,
pushing the conversation back to,
it's like I'm giving him,
just like I've told you all those verses about protesting funerals and why we
have to go and do this and the importance of it and why we have to thank God for
these tragedies,
because God is sovereign and he's in control.
So I'm,
I'm talking about the scripturally,
like the justifying all these things and he kept pushing it back to,
cause he's not super well versed in the Bible.
Um,
so he didn't know how to,
it's like,
I see that the Bible says these things,
but what about the family?
Like I just cannot imagine going and doing these things to people.
And so this is all happening like on as I'm,
so I'm also still having conversations on Twitter with so many other people.
So it's like Twitter became this like empathy machine for me.
Like so it's not just like on a picket line where,
where people are butting heads and you know,
arguing and debating and,
and yelling and it's,
I'm,
yes,
having these,
they can be kind of aggressive conversations,
but I'm also seeing like photos of their cats and then you know,
exchanging,
you know,
joking with their friends.
And so I'm seeing a side of people and sort of being immersed in this community
in a way that I had never been before.
And so it was really,
it's like,
I'm trying to say like when you say,
why did you leave like theirs,
it took,
it was so much sort of happening,
you know,
around this time.
So when by the time this like pile up of things,
um,
you know,
and I'm processing it as I'm going through this,
I'm also talking to my sister,
uh,
and,
and she was the only and other people in the church,
but she was the only person,
if I ever had a doubt or a question or a like,
if I thought we're doing something wrong here,
she was the only person who would say,
yeah,
you're right.
That doesn't make sense that I should say my sister is,
um,
creative and artistic and had a like a little bit of a reputation for being kind
of rebellious,
not as like submissive as ma,
me and our other sister.
Um,
so it was just this dynamic of,
uh,
you know,
between the two of us where she was the only person that could fully articulate
my thoughts and feelings too.
Um,
and so when I first thought of leaving and I turned around and I thought I
literally,
it was,
we were painting at a friend's house,
painting the walls,
and I,
I turned around to set my paint brush down.
I thought it had to go and leave that second.
And I turned around and saw my sister and,
uh,
I thought I can't leave without talking to her.
So the next day I,
um,
she came home from work over the lunch hour and we would always like go up to my
room and we were talking about all these doubts we were having and I was crying
and I put my head in her lap and,
and I couldn't even art,
like articulating the idea of leaving was too much like an aids.
It's terrifying.
Um,
and it's just seemed like impossible.
And I said,
what if we weren't here?
And she said,
what do you mean?
And I said,
what if we were somewhere else?
And so that starts this conversation where,
you know,
I cannot let go of all the things that I thought that the church was doing
wrong,
that are where our theology was wrong,
where we were applying it wrong.
I mean in a way that that was destructive and unscriptural.
Um,
and she kept pushing the conversation back to we're never going to see our
family again.
We're going to lose everyone and everything that's ever been important to us.
There is no hope outside this church.
All the things that we had learned about outsiders that you know,
that they were evil and they could never truly love each other or care about
care about one another.
They're really just enabling one another on the path to how so.
And so this,
this back and forth,
you know,
it goes on for about four months before we finally actually left.
And,
uh,
it was as bad or worse is,
and it could have imagined.
But to get back to the
bad or worse,
you could have ever imagined.
So I should say,
so you left.
How did you leave?
Uh,
we were talking to my parents and,
you know,
and it was another,
another issue had come up and I,
I couldn't,
we couldn't,
it was a battle that we weren't gonna fight again.
We,
we,
we can,
I should say in those four months,
I kept trying to,
to articulate these doubts in a way that the church would accept,
like trying to convince them,
not being as like,
but as time went on,
I became more and more open about,
about these questions and doubts.
Um,
and I,
I just,
I couldn't,
we couldn't fight it anymore.
I just looked at grace and I said,
we have to go.
And cause we,
and I should say also,
we had already been packing.
Like we had,
we had started packing our things about a little over a month before that and we
had started like taking boxes to our friend's house.
Um,
and with the understanding,
he's actually our,
he was our high school English teacher,
um,
that we had kept up with on Twitter.
And he basically told him,
you know,
if something changes,
if the church changes and these things get better,
uh,
then we'll,
we'll take all our stuff back and just pretend like none of this ever happened.
And he was just,
you know,
understanding and compassionate and,
and really supportive.
Um,
but so we had done all this stuff already,
but we actually had to go and pack the rest of our things.
So we walked out of our parents' bedroom and went and started packing and,
you know,
people started coming,
my brother and some of the elders and my aunt,
my cousin,
you know,
people,
I,
we were very close,
like our whole,
my whole life revolved around the church.
And so to look these people in the face and say that,
you know,
this,
the,
you know,
the US,
them mentality,
it,
the bonds that are created in environments like that are incredibly strong.
At least they were in our church.
And again,
most of these people are also in my family.
Um,
so it was,
it was awful.
Uh,
and,
um,
you know,
crying and packing and trying to explain to them why,
why we're leaving and I can hardly talk,
you know,
be just,
just,
I was so overwhelmed,
but,
um,
they actually had to go back the next day with a u haul to get the rest of our
stuff or our parents helped us pack.
It's not,
it's not one of those,
uh,
like there are some groups like that where they don't want you to lead.
They'll,
they'll try to stop you from leaving.
Like I heard,
um,
the Scientology,
the Miscavige I can burn us for it.
Ron.
Yeah.
He was talking about like,
like actual,
um,
obstacles to you leaving,
like physically.
Like they're not going to,
you can't get out of the gate.
Like nothing like that.
You know,
my,
they always would say,
this is a volunteer army and if you don't want to be here and then you don't
belong here.
So it's just the,
uh,
it's the threat of losing everything and
being ostracized by,
and just sort of expelled into this world that you believe and have always
believed is,
is evil and without hope and doomed.
So how'd you do it?
How did the,
your,
you got all your stuff packed.
People are coming in,
they're saying,
yeah.
I mean like they're,
they're,
they're trying to convince us,
but once they understand that we're not being convinced that would,
that,
you know,
they,
they walked away.
So I mean that night our dad dropped us off at a hotel and then Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Like it's,
it's,
it's so immediate that you become this,
you become other,
you become an outsider at like in the next morning when he went back,
I rang the doorbell,
I rang the doorbell and I lived in that house from the day I was born.
Whoa.
Felt like you had to ring the doorbell,
but this is not my world anymore.
Wow.
Chris was like,
why don't you ring the doorbell?
And it was like,
there's,
there's no other,
there is nothing else.
Like,
it's,
this is not our home and it says not.
So we go and,
you know,
we're packing all of our things.
It was just,
it was awful just to,
I had been in those four months I had been so terrified of,
because I know knowing what was coming,
like just imagine you're going to lose everyone in your life.
They're just,
you're just going to like,
you're not going to like how your parents met and fell in love or like your
grandparents and family recipes and photos and memories.
And what did the houseless I'm like taking photos and voice recordings and just
all the time,
like an every,
it was just,
it's just,
it's overwhelming.
It's just,
um,
so let's go back to your first job.
What was it?
What was the first job?
I worked at a,
um,
very briefly like,
so I should say my sister and I,
we were in,
it was a couple months before I actually got a job.
Um,
we spent the first month with,
um,
a cousin of mine who had left the church a few years earlier.
She lived really close.
She had left her as well.
Yeah.
So you guys knew some people had made it out.
Right.
But like the thing is it,
there's,
there's so many,
my sister calls them mind fucks.
Right?
So like the thing about people who leave is that they are demonized more than
anybody else.
Like even more than gays or Jews or any other outsider.
It's x members who get the worst.
You hear the worst things about them because they knew the truth and they
rejected it.
Right.
So I was w w when it came,
when I thought of leading,
like the last thing on my mind was that I could go to an ex member.
I thought,
you can't trust them.
They're people like,
so it's,
it's just this whole,
uh,
this intensely negative,
instinctive reactions to those things.
But obviously I overcame it.
And I reached out to her a few weeks before we left and she was amazing.
Like within,
I hadn't talked to her in three and a half years and had said all kinds of
terrible things,
you know,
about her,
um,
after she left.
But,
um,
but she was wonderful and she said like,
within like 30 seconds of like when I,
when she understood that I was planning to leave,
uh,
I want you to come live with me.
And it was,
it was amazing.
And,
uh,
so kind.
And so where I've lived there for about a month,
um,
my sister was still in school,
so she was,
we were traveling back to camp,
the Topeka,
sorry.
It's like,
so it's a half an hour from my cousin's house and you know,
four days a week while she was still in school.
And so we,
but we were constantly running into our family and driving by the pickets cause
they'd pick it every day and to be guest several times a day and,
uh,
like at the grocery store and on campus.
And so it was just,
we needed to get away.
So we ended up going to deadwood,
South Dakota.
Um,
my brother had been a fan of the TV show and,
uh,
and uh,
it just seemed like a nice,
quiet,
like placement.
How many people went with you?
It was you,
your sister,
and your brother.
No,
it was just,
just you and your sister?
My sister.
Yeah.
Did anybody else join you after a while?
I have a brother who left about a year and a half after my sister and I did.
And I have another brother who left about eight years before I did.
Wow.
So another seven.
There's 11 kids.
So seven are still at home and four of us are out to talk to them.
Yeah.
The,
the people who are out.
Yeah.
What about the people that were in?
No,
they won't have anything to do with us.
They're just like,
I've talked your mom.
No,
no.
Uh,
sh they,
well,
the thing is like,
so back to Twitter,
like that's how I know what that,
what they're up to.
Like I said,
I see folks like they post photos,
like I'm watching my little brother grow up on their photos on Twitter and see
what my parents want.
I'm on.
It's awful.
I mean it's,
it's,
I'm glad,
I'm so glad to be living now and not,
you know,
before social media where I can actually see these things and,
and know what they're up to.
And a little bit about how they're to want to reach out.
I do.
Yeah.
I mean,
I do on,
on Twitter,
you know,
there's this great about Twitter.
Um,
sometimes like I have,
they blocked me on my main account.
Not all of them,
but a lot of them are mom block you.
Uh,
she actually created,
she,
she got kicked off of Twitter at one point,
so she had to create a new again.
So she didn't block me on her new account yet.
Um,
but our old account.
Yeah.
Wow.
Um,
yeah.
Their mom blocks you on Twitter.
That's big thing,
right?
Really terrible.
See that you're blocked.
What does that,
what does that lump in your throat like?
Just want you to imagine like,
I can't believe,
like,
it's so hard to think back to like,
I was incredibly close with my mom and I love her and I miss her.
Like I used to make coffee for her every morning and like we'd go on walks
together and
um,
wow.
Actually,
I,
I saw her to pick it a little over a year ago.
She didn't,
she didn't say anything to me.
She didn't even talk to,
you know,
she,
she couldn't like baby that came from her body,
loved you and raised you.
She can't like,
it's,
so like when I think about like when I was at the church,
and this is one of the hardest things to articulate,
I mean to that,
the feeling of like when somebody leaves,
like there is no interaction.
So some people would ask like,
well what if you saw her at such a place,
you know,
wherever at the grocery store or whatever.
Like what,
what would you say?
They would ask me this while I was still at the church and it's so,
it's like,
uh,
I,
the only thing I can compare it to is like,
it's like dividing by zero.
Like the situation does not exist.
Like there's nothing there.
The idea of trying to talk to her,
it is impossible.
Right.
And go crazy.
That's the call.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's the,
like in Jehovah's Witnesses,
they call it a dis fellowshipping,
right?
Yeah.
They all habit.
Excommunication Qology houses.
They all have it.
Yeah.
It's one of the ways they control people to fear of alienation and the fear to
be calming like them.
Yeah,
exactly.
So they'll talk to gay people,
they'll talk to people with rainbow shirts on,
they'll talk to ex soldiers,
they'll talk to those people.
They won't talk to you.
Right.
That's insane.
But this is one of your mind on acid when I,
um,
one of the great things about Twitter and,
and just the Internet in general is that it's a thing where it's like,
they obviously like my little brothers for instance,
like they are,
you know,
hearing all this bad stuff about,
my sister and me,
anybody who leaves,
they all,
they'll hear bad things about us.
But the good thing about the internet is like they can go on,
they can go to my Twitter account and see what I'm actually saying.
So I'm still,
I go through these phases where like I,
I,
I will tweet and then I get like,
I can't,
I just like the fear of judgment I guess from my family.
And I just,
I just choose to focus on other things and not post things on Twitter,
but like,
I still,
I follow them on this other account that I created that's not blocked.
Right.
And it's just WBC accounts.
So like,
and I see like things that they say and,
uh,
like doctrines that I now believe are unscriptural.
And so like,
I will tweet them,
you know,
versus like,
I want this contradicts you.
Like,
and try to like basically doing what I was doing for them now against them,
like just in this,
in these instances.
And,
and so there is some engagement a little bit with my family on Twitter because,
especially because of any,
like anything that I do publicly,
so maybe something about this,
I dunno,
but like when my ted talk came out,
there was a couple of articles and like,
people were tweeting it a lot and,
and,
uh,
so my uncle and my aunt both were tweeting,
tweeting me and tweeting about me.
And so I was,
you know,
we're having this rub,
Rti,
I guess,
like just,
you know,
going back and forth about these,
these Bible verses.
And debating.
And so all of that stuff,
it's,
I hope at some point,
hopefully we'll have,
we'll have some effect and in some ways it already has.
So like the day that I left,
there was a,
we're going to get to that job sometimes here.
The day that I left my,
one of my cousins,
you know,
came into my bedroom while I was crying and packing and I was asking like,
just very calmly,
this is my best.
My best friend,
she was a year older than me,
is a year older than me and,
uh,
she's asking me why we're leaving and I'm describing a lot of things.
And one of the two I described specifically at two signs,
uh,
one of them was the death penalty for fags and another one was facts can't
repent.
And,
uh,
she sent me a message the next morning and like I was describing versus that I
thought,
you know,
contradicted those two signs.
And,
uh,
the following morning she sent me a message,
a text message to super early in the morning,
just like,
uh,
just joined me out,
basically like that.
I know that that Leviticus and Romans one,
like the death penalty,
like there's no,
there's,
you have no argument.
Like so,
so what's your really your problem?
And,
um,
so,
and then for a while after I left,
like those signs were like everywhere.
Like she's holding my cousin changes her profile picture on Twitter to her
holding those two signs,
like screaming into the camera and like one of the elders like making a snow
angel with those two signs and it's like,
so they're just like doubling down on this,
right.
And uh,
so this goes on,
it's like during this time,
like I'm talking about it in like giving a few interviews,
like talking about it,
they're like on Twitter a little bit.
Um,
like reiterating the verses that contradict them.
And then like,
after more than two years,
like I wake up one morning and I check,
I'm checking their twitters and uh,
there was a blog post and they said,
uh,
about that fags can't repent sign.
And I was like,
oh my God.
It's like,
like opened the blog post and it's a,
for the first time ever they had publicly disavowed assign and using the same
Bible verses that I had been.
And I know that's like a very small point in the grand scheme of things.
Right.
But that's,
that's reason,
that's critical reasoning.
But,
but like,
so this is,
this is the goal,
right?
So like to knowing this is like story behind it.
I don't,
it was after my brother left,
so I don't really know,
you know,
at no,
nobody who's left since then.
I also,
I have to do,
actually have my cousins have left since then also.
Um,
but none of them have any understanding of like,
of,
of what happened.
So I don't know.
I,
and I'm not like,
I'm not trying to take credit.
I should also say like,
well,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Like it just
changes possible.
It gets into their head that what they're doing,
it's,
this is not in any way the teachings of Christ.
Right.
I mean,
like the thing is like some,
some of it is,
some of us.